I believe in my abilities to complete
this song in one take
it is now take 17 but I will do it I
will
starting now take 18 19 take 20 take 21
take 22 here we go
take 23
there's a place where you don't wanna be
where people with I constantly and I
never die in normal ways it's
preposterous but still cliche when
you're drug dealers and kill your mom
and a doula by jumping up her head with
a side than the pool well they're not
saying it it makes sense they're just
interpreting the actors this is the pump
to every television crime show from CSI
to Columbo and I think you know what's
in store that guy we met in the first 15
minutes will come back cuz you know he
did it I don't think they're trying
anymore and I'm getting bored
well they're seeming all over the crime
suit something the superconscious even
testing machine and the
nabis gets a hit but it looks like he
might still get away with it but the
final piece of and intense totally stops
the bad guys defense and he breaks down
a bran of everyone and tell them exactly
how it was done
this is the pot to every television
crime show from CSI to Columbo and I
think you know what's in store that guy
we met in the first 15 minutes we'll
come back cuz you know he did it they're
not even trying anymore and I'm getting
bored and by the middle of the first
season murder is eclipsed by sexual
tension and I guess that probably
happens a lot since crime-solving people
are always so hot but then a serial
killer kidnaps the girl and they
promised to save her if it costs in the
world and they find her two seconds
before she dies and they hug and they
live in this girl and they cry
this is the block to every television
crime show from CSI to Columbo and I
think you know what's in store that guy
we met in the first 15 minutes come back
because you know he did it they're not
even trying anymore
and I'm getting Bo
bird so bored I could be like data Korea
said I'll be like that was a one taker
take 1 or 1 wanna fire it doesn't matter
what he says as long as he takes off his
glasses first it's like Oh even Caruso
took off his glasses and said something
dumb you know what's better than
television crime shows john green's
books actually all books little
anti-smoking Korean baby keychains
low-fat homestyle canned chicken soup
fake hands video games and also YouTube
YouTube is a pretty big pretty big poner
pretty poner that's like what this
guitar is right now my poner haha i find
that to be a very funny you know how
Woody Guthrie's guitar killed fascists
my guitar is a poner can I use that joke
is that ok there's no way I could not
use that joke remember down there in the
comments if you leave john green's
favorite ten word comment of the day you
will receive a free copy of the
paperback of Paper Towns and I know you
want it oh and by the way I recently had
an idea I think it would be really cool
if people submitted clips of themselves
doing this and that's all and we can use
that to end the show you don't even have
to make the noise because I'll put the
noise in but just like and you can send
those to our new address Hank and John
at gmail.com